you know I had a conversation one time
with former Chief of Staff General John
Kelly and we had a cocktail we were at a
financial conference he was the guest
speaker and I candidly asked him a
question I said what do you enjoy the
most about working for president Trump
and what what did you least enjoy the
most or what was your biggest issue with
them and he goes my biggest problem
with President Trump was that he was not
willing to listen to experts this is his
former Chief of Staff General John Kelly
telling me this is what he said okay
um we just went down the list Gary Cohen
Mick Mulvaney General Mattis uh General
Kelly Bill Barr you said it was
potentially a bad hire uh even Mike
Pence at this point is not exactly in
best favor with Trump although I think
he was a very loyal Vice President John
Bolton not exactly a fan
um if Trump is elected again yes what
how much should he actually listen to
experts and how much should he go with
his gut like you even gave the example
of you think that fauci lied to him
right who he keeps around him so if
you're Trump you know that at the time
right well you never know if someone's
lying to you up front like you kind of
find out in the end but yeah to be clear
yeah uh if Trump gets elected again how
much should he trust the advisers around
him who should we just went through this
list versus just kind of go with his gut
and do it himself what do you recommend
so
um I had an interesting relationship
um with John Kelly
I admire a man who puts on a uniform and
puts his life at risk out in places like
Afghan like Afghanistan and has a and
and basically
sacrifices one of his sons to that work
because he lost the son there
um Kelly
was not Suited
for being Chief of Staff in the Trump
White House he should have stayed at the
Department of Homeland Security he
understood border security and National
Security issues and he would have done a
good job there but when Kelly came in
um he committed the the Corey
Lewandowski Dave bossi ultimate sin was
he didn't understand to let Trump beat
Trump and letting Trump be Trump means
actually being able to listen not just
to experts but to everybody and what
Donald Trump loves to do every day you
know he's got a discipline he's the
hardest working man in Show Business
trust me on that
um what he loves to do every day is scan
all of the media right he reads
everything he's watching TV picking up
all that and then he's on the phone
most of the day or he's got in-person
meetings with people asking them about
issues and he values
people in the streets opinions as much
as he does some of the so-called experts
and so
what Kelly says that
what Kelly means is that he wouldn't
listen to some of his advisors who he
figured out pretty early on didn't
weren't on the Trump train
um and Kelly wouldn't let him
listen to others I mean Kelly used to
eavesdrop on conversations
and see the boss what the boss would do
at night you know if you wanted to talk
to the boss and I had to do this a
number of times it's like it's like
Kelly won't let you talk to him so I
just called him a night right you know
it's like and then the next day it's
like Kelly what'd you call the boss for
he said I had to talk to him he's like
I'm a I'm an assistant of the president
I'm a highest rank I don't report to you
I report that you have that conversation
but the point is that
um that's a bad rap that's just wrong
and Kelly's mistake when he came in is
he fell in
with the wrong people particularly on
the trade issue I mean he went right
with mnuchin and Cohn and Rob Porter the
staff secretary office and they did
everything possible with Kelly helping
him to stop the stealing the Loon of
tariffs to stop the China tariffs and
and the boss like looks up like six
months later he goes you know where's my
peter that was his rallying right he
pulls me in there's a famous scene in
the book about how I go in there mono
imano with Gary Cohn and it's like it's
like the boss finally says no we're
going to do this and and we did it and
then shortly thereafter cones out the
friggin door but that was Kelly's fault
because Kelly
tried to wall the boss off and and wall
people like me off who supported the
Trump stuff
which he viewed frankly as dangerous and
he he went with the the the regular line
and you know it's that's the sad thing
was there's a there's a poignant Moment
In the book where we're sitting in
Buenos Aires Argentina and it's like one
of Kelly's last days you know he's out
the door he's sitting right by me and he
apologizes
and he basically says you know it's like
you were one of the good guys and I'm
sorry I didn't get that right and I said
you know John that's cool man we're good
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]